it's gonna be the shadow on this wall
and you're just gonna have to deal with
that that's my attitude for 2020 no I
made myself you know their life is
different now so I want him to start
well okay that standard that sentence I
wanted to start and I did we've started
we've begun this is my first like
official video of the year and I wanted
to start it off rambley but positive and
rambley and positive Rama tips ram
motive sounds like a geometry turn or
like what bro boys use as like a
confirmation from when you've had
consensual sex with someone that you Ram
it in RAM ative here we are this is a
video about things that I like right now
things I'm thinking about right now some
highlights from my holiday time so you
don't even get some of the highlights
the majority the highlights you can
listen to memory and I stalk ass this
might get weird every Wednesday in fact
it might be out right now when this
video is out so if this wets your
whistle then go check that out where did
we get that for his wedding a whistle is
a whistle term for a cooter because it
can start the games off the game signal
for penalties not much has changed but
oh you might notice that I'm wearing an
oversized sweatshirt the comfy I
purchased this while I was very
intoxicated after watching an episode of
shark tank in which they pitched the
comfy oh I this is what I call hugging
my shape in all the right places look at
this I should have been at the Golden
Globes also stained just how I like it
I've been living in this since the end
of last year if you follow me on
instagram which you should if you like
not knowing what's you're going to get
and when you're gonna get it got back
last Tuesday and I've been wearing it
every single day since then because you
can it's a blanket on your body so it
like masks all of the potential odors
that you might have underneath I'm
basically just Dutch oven in myself all
day long and it's great it's the second
week in January which means you're
probably disappointed with yourself and
all the resolutions that you made that's
why
I didn't make any resolutions not on
purpose I just didn't want to think
about it so I didn't think about it
basically I've already succeeded in my
resolution you might you know have
dipped in the things that you wanted to
accomplish that's why this video I
wanted it to be positive to let you know
everything's okay everything's okay I
know a lot of things are not okay from
right now right here at this moment with
you watching this video everything's
okay and that's also oil okay I should
organize my thoughts but as an editing
as far as editing is for speaking of
okay the last video that I posted at the
end of last year things were not okay
and so many of you loved so many
incredible comments sent me messages so
many of like people I know in the real
world like reached out other content
creators and it was just so
overwhelmingly
sweet that I thank you for also sharing
a lot of those feelings that you have
that are similar with me I respect you
so much for opening up and for reaching
out and I just am really grateful and
thankful hence why I think I feel so
much more positive right now that and
also I'm on my fourth day of sober
January as of when I'm shooting this
video clear mine full can't lose because
there's no game I'm not playing games
no games sometimes when I get
overwhelmed with how beautiful people I
I get to hide in my comfy look how
multifunction this is I guess this is
kind of like a stream of consciousness
video to which so you know when you look
at your phone here like one why did I
come to this - I know three where is it
for found it okay
I've been listened to a lot of Unser
self by Gary John Bishop one like
halfway through it I'm taking my time
and one of the most recent things he
talks about that can keep us from
growing and changing evolve a few things
success in whatever way is certainty
versus uncertainty I have struggled with
this so much in my past being a person
thrives on certainty knowing who's gonna
be at the party knowing when I have to
go to this thing knowing what's gonna
happen just keeping to my comfort zone I
always thought that it wasn't that kind
of person because I did I travelled a
lot I worked a lot and I met a lot of
new people all the time
and so I felt like oh I thrive on
uncertainty uh-uh when you are a person
that drives uncertainty you just stay in
your own little bubble of things you
know for sure I Eve sitting in my house
watching reality TV I know exactly how
that's gonna go and I can succeed at
that all damn day every day but if you
think back on the times in your life
when you've had a major breakthrough or
real growth or a true success it's
usually come with some measure of
uncertainty attached to it and those are
the only moments in which we can grow
meet new people is putting yourself in
an uncertain situation diving into an
uncertain creative project that really
struck me because it's a very simple
concept that I've heard many times but
it's just nice to get a little thing
reminder of it at the start of this year
and I wanted to share that with you guys
is something that I'm gonna be actively
trying to work on this year is getting
out of my comfort zone again getting
into uncertain situations not better
safe otherwise you potato but potato
thrives when potato becomes fries and
potato becomes chips or potato becomes
baked potato becomes baked times - what
else is going on is anyone else doing
sober January I'm doing sober January
ish meaning I have a trip plan at the
end of the month and I would really like
to have some dumb drinks on the but
until then I'm and I think mamrie gets -
so our podcasts are gonna be like highly
recommend again this might give your
every Wednesday Oh a lot of you were
telling me that you wanted me to do more
good news is and I want to do more good
news is - for instance the good news is
that the Eagles didn't win their last
game and now they're out of the playoffs
so now I don't have to feel the anxiety
of hoping that they get to the Super
Bowl that's off my plate whoo here's
another piece of good news I got some
fun Christmas gifts I know it can seem a
little egotistical and like
vain when people tell you or show you
what they got for Christmas and I know
this might trigger you and that because
this is a very it's gonna make some of
you feel insecure about what you got who
didn't get for Christmas and I'm
preemptively sorry for that but my mom
got me something pretty lit I know I'm
sorry I'm sorry I usually don't give in
to this type of vanity it's not Gucci I
know it's this scary astral doll I guess
this has now been passed down to me my
grandmother on her side the family is
from England so when my mom was really
really little the only trip that they
went on they went to England to visit
some of her family and she saved up her
money and she bought this troll doll oh
I accidentally held its hand
oh she brought it all the way back from
England and when I was younger at one
employment older brother and I shared a
room in our attic and she put this on a
shelf and it would just stare at us
every night when we went to bed it gave
me such horrendous nightmares and they
couldn't fall asleep and no one ever
talked about it British didn't talk
about her feelings no one ever talked
about this scary a stroll on the shelf
or where it came from or why it was
there if it could go my mom found it in
her storage like last year and texted
photos to my brothers and I and we both
all of us were like that thing is
nightmarish and I am triggered and I
guess I at the end of the text thread
said but I kind of want it so be careful
what you ask for and they carry this
around the East Coast for like a whole
week until we came back to California so
this was really fun to put in suitcases
everywhere because no matter where you
are it's always making eye contact with
you so if you think you're controlling
me sorry my dance card is full I can't
get rid of this because I will be cursed
good news is this lives in my house now
speaking of monster sorry I grabbed you
by your hair and I feel like you sent an
energy that that was not okay I'm so
sorry
another gift I got my stepmom had this
painting made for me it's in the plastic
because I got them grubby hands and I
don't want to get it dirty
it's my woman named Michelle Collins
it's this drawing of goose and with
watercolor and
if you look close she's wearing
sunglasses that's got my face in the
sunglasses and she's a little Derby hat
on and she has no idea that a woman in
New Jersey and artist in New Jersey got
commissioned to make they say they the
gifts that you get for Christmas really
telling you a lot about who you are how
you are how old you are I think this
adds up that's been a real hoot I'm
really afraid of this draw the other
good news is is that this video is
sponsored by something that I talk about
all the time and love very much anyway
that I'm gonna talk to you about right
now because at this critical time in the
year where we're all you know might be
floundering from our resolutions but
aren't you know total pieces of this
could really help you out
it's care of I've talked about them in
videos in the past and I literally only
have one packet of their vitamins left
that I didn't take this morning because
I was saving them so I could show you
them in this video so I'm off balance
because I haven't had my b12 this
morning and that's the kind of energy to
tell you about sponsor I travelled with
these I brought all these packs with me
to the East Coast and was just taking
them to the face you get it in with them
vitamins Rambo did Cara was just a
wellness brand that makes it super easy
for you to find vitamins and supplements
stuff that I don't know how to get on my
own oh to like a store and it's just
walls and walls and walls the walls of
things and letters and words and then
other like healthier people that with
like their yoga mats just like knowing
exactly what they're gonna get and I
said they're gonna comfy going I win do
you go on the website you take the care
of quiz and it helps you find tailored
vitamins and supplements that are
specific to what you fill out and then
they value a box like this very cute
very chic this ain't your grandma's box
full of vitamins and it's full of these
individual packets these daily packets
and they have your name on them how
customizable and cute it's and no one
else can take them but you and they have
a little fact on them this one says
expressing gratitude has been proven to
generate a brighter outlook on life and
lower stress please and thank you how
inappropriate is that [ __ ]
this is what happens when I don't take
my vitamins when I went home
holidays I did a lot of terrible
terrible terrible things to my body but
this what's the one redeeming thing
every morning I woke up and I took these
and I felt like that balance - what's a
Bloody Mary you take the quiz that asks
you about your diet your lifestyle and
the things that you want to improve on
having expert recommendations for you so
you can take the expert recommendations
which is what I did because I don't
trust myself but I'm learning to
gratitude season thank you or you can
customize it however you want you can
also super easily change up your packs
month to month they make it so easy for
you and you can get 50% 5-0 50% half off
your first care of order when you go to
take care up calm and use the offer code
grace h50 again 50% off take care of
calm grace h50 Thank You Cara Oh also I
clean my laptop before this and that
hoof made a world of difference today I
cannot believe I traveled with this open
in front of people I cleaned it often it
was was a lot of scum an archaeological
dig when you're just dust and stuff off
and then you suddenly find a fossil you
like that's been under there that pile
of dirt the whole time so if I haven't
answered your emails it's because I
didn't know where my keyboard was on my
laptop what else you know what I'm not
drinking for the month of January I've
been imbibing in some of the organic
products and then I watched Newsies last
night for the first time with Elliott
because he really loves that movie and
it is so much Christian Bale isn't it
there's so much going on in that movie I
couldn't handle it I'm still having a
good time I can't unsee it this poor
dude that's an hours-long and very
confusing two qualities that everyone
wants in a film oh I haven't been on
social media as much just because as
soon as I look at it I get very pop oh
wow I forgot what is it called
we found this show on Disney Plus called
pick of the litter and oh my god there
are good people in this world there are
some good goods out there in the bad bad
it's a series chronicling puppies that
are trained to become guide dogs for the
blind but they don't all make it and it
documents the process and there are
volunteers that raise these puppies till
they get to a certain stage to see if
they get accepted into the advanced
training equals five or six six six dogs
following them through their entire
training process and you're following
the families that are taking them in
volunteering to take them in to train
them to only give them away 18 months
later I wept
I wet to giants like slip and slides
right down the front of my face highly
highly recommend if you want to feel
good about people and a little bad boy
well I've been rambling for a long time
but this was really fun and I hope you
guys enjoyed this video and I hope that
this was a good little time away from
whatever did leave me some comments down
below on what kind of videos you'd like
to see me do this year donate to the
Australian Red Cross if you can because
they're going through some rough stuff
right now I'll put a link in the
description box below crash this YouTube
channel we're gonna make some more stuff
this year we're gonna live in an
uncertainty baby other than that I don't
know
that hasn't changed thank you I can't
really good thing
I